hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Brandi
price we're gonna review the trailer
today for a film called outcast it stars
Nicolas Cage and Hayden Christensen a
duo I've been waiting for for the
longest time two of Hollywood's most
powerful actors coming together I read
some comments on this trailer already
and saw that it wasn't the most positive
feedback it's pretty popular trailer so
I was like I gotta see what everyone's
[ __ ] watching and hating them but I'm
going in with an open mind to choose you
because he knows you're strong
if you don't help us we will be killed
you will be if you stay here and the
silver mountains they've said to me
about it spies your brother isn't
anything you mean the white ghost
take all the white and the white ghost
in 1014
if Sheen becomes king this land will
burn you are his friend he believes his
dad is right the blood we spill here's
on our late
what is old must be paid
you're my blood
to the town each and every one of us
every time Nicolas Cage talk I was
trying not to laugh I know his accent
was so bad and his body his mannerisms
with his face he had going on funny
one-liners yeah I mean it looks like it
looks like a well-made movie right yeah
like you won't see it on sci-fi exactly
something like that or NBC you can see
that piece of [ __ ] on NBC's you know
their made-for-tv movies you can't see
it
Hayden Christensen I never thought I'd
say this but he looks good because he's
being compared to Nicolas Cage in this
film I was thinking that I was like I
normally don't find him to be like the
only good thing in a movie but I'm
watching it going but it's cuz he's
doing a better job Nicolas Cage it kind
of reminded me the last airbender was a
terrible movie but but all the Asian
actors in it were the best ones yeah I
mean the trailer starts off as if we're
watching an Asian cinematic piece yeah
that's what I was thinking too so when
Hayden Christensen showed up I was like
like this isn't House of Flying Daggers
yeah what the [ __ ] is this even the
Asian cinematic part I was like looks
okay like honestly at all the hey I love
I love Asians Asian women to their dice
Mazen woman I mean I like Asian women
but I don't like like yeah there's so
much things you could say from this one
trailer that I can't even gather my
thoughts right now I feel like the title
text of the trailer like I feel like the
text of the trailer but they kept
showing on screen yeah was more epic
than what the trailer was giving us it
looked like a film that is failing at
being epic like it's being dragged down
into the slumps if you look at the what
is it called the font yes that stuff you
look at the font that it kind of looks
similar to The Hobbit yeah no it looks
like it's a cheap imitation of a lot of
[ __ ] we've all
already seen before mm-hmm like it
doesn't even look it doesn't they have
like this
triumphant music and trying to make it
epic what I'm like this doesn't feel a
big at all like Arnold Schwarzenegger to
come out at any turn yeah that would
that would have been cooler if I did
that he's like I'll be back Arnold voice
yeah I don't get the tone they're trying
to communicate in this trailer yeah like
is it supposed to be some serious
picture with some humor this is supposed
to be intentionally bad like what are we
exactly
going into this movie to watch is
supposed there's no romance I don't
quite get what like what's the [ __ ] is
supposed to be the appeal of elements I
think also that it's just exactly cuz
you never really know like what is he
what's what's the enemy like they're
doing what and why is he he's the white
what do you think white goes through
some yeah the white ghost
I thought Nicolas Cage and Hayden
Christensen were enemies but apparently
they're friends like whose are really
confusing I am hahahahahaha I feel like
Nicolas Cage here's the problem with
Nicolas Cage and Hayden Christensen's
performance Hayden Christensen looks
like he's taking it way too seriously
and Nicolas Cage looks like he is not
taking it seriously at all it looks like
he's aware he's in a shitty film you
know kind of like a lot of his movies
lately but but it's funny because like
you're saying that and yeah it is like
he's aware as an actor and as a person
instead of just being immersed in
whatever it is yeah like how he used to
do like 15 years ago
or something yeah like he hasn't been on
set like a million times
yeah they both seemed a little bit
improperly cast I don't know maybe
because I don't know what the [ __ ]
things about oh my god Asian filled
cinema it's kind of distracting to me
yeah okay Last Samurai had Ken Watanabe
that like made him famous in America and
but he's amazing yeah no he's amazing
this trailer is like look at all this
Asian cinema reflection we're trying to
do we're gonna cast two white guys but
not put anyone in this film that's Asian
that will really stand out and that kind
of bothers me maybe
my hand Asian sign what do you mean I'm
saying they could have got him one Asian
actor to look like he's gonna be a
standout performance well they had the
girl she has a part like a bigger part
and more a significant part hopefully
this movie is what launches her career
yes and really make something of her
whoever you are Asian lady what I will
admit about it though is like it looks
like it could be a cheesy fun time I
like watching films that are bad where
they're so bad that you can't help but
enjoy yourself at how bad it is like the
room like the room or streetfighter with
John Coffey it looks like something
Mystery Science Theater would make fun
of yeah but that's part of why I want to
watch it I'm definitely not going to
theaters this is the kind of thing we're
said in theaters or on demand I'm like
with the Flex gonna take their time out
to watch this in the theaters if you can
just get it on your television angry
maybe they'll do a simultaneous release
just like they did with snowpiercer yeah
but snowpiercer is a kind of film where
I'm gonna say you know someone wants to
see in the tears but it's pretty yeah
this it's not like I don't want to watch
it aren't you really funny like
one-liners and I don't really remember
one was like we have blood on our swords
it looked like they were just trying to
jam packed everything we've seen from
other movies before but on a much
smaller budget it's at the right budget
for were there going for something that
looks epic but they don't have enough
money to make it look the way that are
trying to make it look anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and brandy
has a channel too does a lot of
independent movie reviews you should go
to her channel huh plug into the channel
or subscribe to the real rejects and
shout outs will continue so go to
facebook.com slash the real rejection
outs and you can earn yourself a
shout-out by saying something that is
interesting like brandy is into big
black penises as long as it's all be
that's fine anything with all babies oh
you out three B's Brandy's big black
penises that's
not IV brandy nope was your name stuck
with you
you said Brandy's big black penises and
penises and maybe you should really say
is Brandy's big black balls but really
these it's all B's it's a ball